okay it's embarrassing for the prime
minister it's embarrassing for the
chancellor but it's done now and he
they've got other things to worry about
no i mean i wish that was the case but
it's not and i hope that conservative
mps listened to the likes of ross altman
and to dominic grieve that i think speak
about the real threat to
our public life when you've got a prime
minister and you just showed with your
clip there
that blatantly lied to the house of the
commons not just once or twice but
repeatedly
this is the first prime minister that's
been found to break the law
and he's walking away from his
responsibilities he's not accepting
responsibilities i wrote to him
yesterday saying that he should be
recalling parliament we need to be
meeting this week and he should be
coming
to offer his resignation he has
overstepped the mark and you know from
the point of view of process and
parliament
if you willfully mislead parliament then
it's not a question or ifs or buts isn't
the question about any dubai
you must resign
and he cannot simply argue that he
didn't know that these events were
parties good grief
this was partying on an industrial scale
that was taking place at westminster it
wasn't just as he's tried to say in his
statement he was breaking the rules no
prime minister you weren't you were
breaking your own laws
and you were breaking the laws
but mr blackford you know we were in the
middle of a global pandemic the prime
minister was and his team were doing
their level best working 24 7 to try and
get as a vaccine to protect us from
kovid 19. we were seeing millions of
people dying around the world we were
certainly one of the first if not the
first country in the world to have that
vaccine that was what the prime minister
presided over he might have had a drink
you know he might have celebrated when
it was his birthday he might have had a
drink in the garden to thank staff for
what they were doing
and now he has to deal with a war in
ukraine he was there risking his own
life uh just a couple of days ago and in
addition to that we can see inflation is
at the highest level in decades
come on he just needs to stay in office
and try and get us through this no he
used to leave office because when
millions of other people were making so
many sacrifices couldn't be with their
loved ones couldn't be with the loved
ones when they were dying
and you had this culture been downing
straight of partying let's not forget
that image of the queen
sitting on her own
her husband's funeral and the night
before a party taking place
within downing street they simply don't
get it and he and those around them
think that the rules don't apply to them
that they can do as they please and
quite frankly it isn't good enough there
has to be morality there has to be
ethics in public life
and that has to be the set of
circumstances that when you cross the
line as he did
as those around him did 50 people
in his operation have been fined
somewhere along the line
there has to be responsibility somewhere
along the line he has to put his hand up
and say look i have done wrong i need to
accept that under those circumstances i
have forfeited the right to govern i
forfeited the right to lead okay but 50
fines um so far there may well be more
that's certainly what we're being led to
believe by the metropolitan police but i
think it was dennis healey who once said
that you don't examine your entrails in
the midst of battle and quite literally
we have a good relationship via the
prime minister with the ukrainian
president now is not the time even if
you feel that he needs to go now is not
the time for that to happen
it's cross-party unity that we stand
with our friends in ukraine that we
stand with president zarenski
of course we stand with our allies in
that as well we call out for putin for
what he is a warmonger
a war criminal but the idea that we need
the prime minister to do that is just
simply bogus let's not forget that the
united kingdom changed prime minister in
both the first and the second world war
this man is a stain on our democracy we
need to show that united front i and
other opposition leaders work
extensively with ben law as the defense
minister but just reflect on this loki
that the previous prime minister theresa
may any time she went to a nato summit
would come back and make a statement in
the house of commons this man that's
saying he's leading the fight against
ukraine went to nato summit two weeks
ago and did not come back to parliament
he doesn't discharge his
responsibilities
for him number 10 is a personal
plaything and we've seen over the course
of the last few years everything that's
going on illegally pro-wroting
parliament lying to the queen the dodgy
poverty contracts stuffing his pals that
give money to the tories into the house
of lords this man doesn't understand how
he should behave as prime minister and
this insult to the people of the united
kingdom
by lying to parliament repeatedly the
first prime minister that breaks the law
quite simply has to go there's no essa
but he has to go okay if it's not about
so let's talk about brexit then should
we for you know whatever your view is on
brexit we are where we are we need the
trade deals in order to get our economy
back up and running again we've seen
what interest rates are doing the prime
minister needs to straddle the world
stage and show that we are a force to be
reckoned with he doesn't need people
bickering with him because he had um a
can of beer or whatever it was for his
birthday it wasn't about a can of year
it was about a culture a party you know
when it comes to brexit myself and
others told them that we needed to have
a proper trading relationship with the
european union we talked about for us
our compromise with the single market
and the customs union he's now got the
shambles of the northern ireland
protocol that's leading to all sorts of
problems because he did a deal that
quite simply doesn't fit the needs of uk
businesses and uk consumers but he's
responsible for that he created that and
what he needed to do was to make sure
that he worked with others to make sure
that he wasn't going to do untold damage
to the uk economy as is now doing
nevertheless he is where he is and it
doesn't look as though he's moving
anytime soon because that is up to the
uh conservative backbenchers and they
are decidedly quiet at the moment
if not him though then whom
well you know this is the tragedy of the
whole thing because it is up to the
conservative mps but they need to do
their job they need to understand that
the public want the prime minister to go
now we should have been doing that this
week i hope that the prime minister
comes to parliament next week there's a
suggestion he might even be away on a
trade trip to india the prime minister
needs to come to the house of commons we
need to have that ability to hold into
account and conservative mps need to
recognize
that they have that responsibility they
have the moral authority to remove this
man that's lied to parliament light to
the public broken the law
they now need to stand up and they need
to accept their own responsibilities
don't run away from
this because at the end of the day if
you do the public will seek the revenge
on someone that can't be trusted in
public office and you cannot accept for
one second that that was then it was the
middle of a pandemic he was doing his
level best along with his team to try to
keep the country safe and by having a
glass of wine or um a karaoke here and
there if that if indeed the prime
minister was attending that or a beer
and a glass and a piece of cake for his
birthday that lasted less than nine
minutes the only thing that he's had to
find for so far uh you can't forgive him
for that you can't find it in your heart
to forgive him for that
16 different events i think it was it
took place over a number of months in
downing street it's that culture it's
that that the rules didn't apply to the
prime minister and his team the rules
were for the little people for the rest
of us frankly it was the contempt
the disregard that showed for the public
and that very important aspect that
people couldn't believe properly
couldn't hug their loved ones and a
prime minister that couldn't care
because he was going to carry on
partying